Hello, everyone. Welcome to Fluid Mechanics 1. This is the lecture for Week 1. Today I am going to introduce fluid mechanics. First, I will discuss the concept of a fluid and define a fluid as a continuum material.
and in a fluid mechanics eventually what you want to do is when there is a pressure difference what will be the force or what will be the velocity at some locations away right so for those kind of analysis we need the dimensions of the flow properties like pressure velocity and stuff like that and then what will be the
We also need the corresponding units. To calculate fluid states, we define a control volume and a control surface. A solid material has well-defined boundaries, but a fluid domain - such as the air around an aircraft or the air in a room - does not always have an obvious boundary.
For flow analysis in a room, should the domain be the entire room or only the flow near your body? Because there is no unique answer, we must define the control volume over which fluid properties will be calculated. This is very important.
For fluid-flow applications, there are two frameworks for describing motion: the Eulerian perspective and the Lagrangian perspective. I will define both, and then discuss important properties of fluids and flows.
important properties of the fluid and flow and one of the most important the properties of the fluid and flow is the viscosity so I will define the fluid viscosity and then there are three basic flow analysis techniques used in fluid mechanics so I will describe that and in fact those will be discussed in chapter 3 and 4 and 5
Fluid mechanics consists of two subjects: fluid statics and fluid dynamics. Fluid statics concerns fluids at rest, whereas fluid dynamics concerns fluids in motion and their spatial and temporal properties.
fluid and when we are saying fluid it includes the gas and also it includes the liquid as well so for example a ship right submarine so we have to think about the liquid the water ocean water surrounding the submarine or if you think about some floating a ship you have to think about both air and water
and when you are considering the air and when you are considering the car and when you are considering car right so then we have to think about the air surrounding the car so all those are classified as a fluid and I'm sure you are taking the solid mechanics course as well as you know controlled course but what makes the fluid most distinctively different from the solid is whether it can resist a shear force or not so if you think about
In the figure, a solid can deform under a shear force and sustain a static deformation. A fluid, however, cannot resist a continuously applied shear stress while remaining at rest.
A liquid subjected to an external shear force continues to move and deform. We therefore distinguish fluids from solids by their response to shear, and we usually treat a fluid as a continuous medium made from aggregated molecules.
But oftentimes we don't have to think about the molecules but often times we don't have to think about the molecules because we don't consider fluid as a summation of distinct or discrete molecules but we just think about aggregated properties of the molecules
So for a gas those molecules are very widely spaced because the density is small and for a liquid
In a liquid, molecules are relatively closely spaced, although the spacing is still larger than the molecular diameter. At ordinary engineering scales, we therefore do not need to track each molecule as an individual particle.
Which means that you don't have to think about the fluid as an individual particle unless you are going away
If you are going away
In extremely rarefied gas, such as at very high altitude or in space, the molecular spacing can become large enough that individual-particle effects matter. At ordinary atmospheric conditions in the troposphere, the continuum model is generally appropriate.
you don't have to worry about the molecule level okay so we consider fluid as a continuum then we will define the density density of the fluid is defined as the as you know density is a mass divided by the volume but in a fluid we don't have a tangible property right so if you think about a region
containing fluid and we are inside that region we are thinking about elemental volume here with its volume is a delta v and we are think about the limiting case of the delta v small down to delta v star and then when it is shrunk down to delta v star then we consider what is the mass elementary mass inside that small shrunken volume that is a density so
The limiting volume v-star is extremely small, about 10 to the minus 9 cubic millimeters for liquids and gases at atmospheric pressure. The plotted density near 1200 kilograms per cubic meter is an illustrative value; the density of water is about 1000 kilograms per cubic meter.
for the air for the air almost like 1.0 right 1.04 kg per meter cube so this density is just arbitrary so let's assume that rho is a 1200 kg per meter cube so there is some some arbitrary material then there is the density of that
that fluid and then if that fluid and then if that is a 1200 kg per meter cube so we consider that as a
of course there will be some variation right so we consider that as a uncertainty okay and then dimensions and units so for the fluid analysis now we will later on you will consider you know the pressure or viscosity and stuff like that so out of a lot of flow properties there are
There are four primary dimensions from which the other dimensions can be derived.
what can be they can be mass length and time and temperature okay so there are the these are the important dimensions and then their units can be defined in two different types
The two unit systems shown here are widely used.
One is the SI system, which is used widely around the world. The other is the BG system, the British Gravitational system.
Mass is denoted by the dimension M. Its SI unit is the kilogram, whereas its BG unit is the slug.
they use a kilogram kg but for the BG unit they use a slug and for the length for the dimensional analysis we use the
Length is denoted by the dimension L. Its SI unit is the meter, and its BG unit is the foot.
right their conversion is one feet is about 30 centimeter or 0.3 meter and then time time is same for SI unit and BG unit right
otherwise people will use a different watch the watch with a different unit that will be so confusing right
so time the unit is the same for SI unit and BG in second and then for the temperature the fourth dimension
important dimension is the temperature it is denoted by the theta then SI unit they use a Kelvin and BG unit
The BG unit of absolute temperature is Rankine, and one kelvin interval equals 1.8 degrees Rankine. In the SI system, the basic dimensions are mass, length, time, and temperature.
In SI, the corresponding basic units are kilograms, meters, seconds, and kelvin. This is called the MLT-theta system of dimensions.
to as a MLT theta system of a dimensions then here the force can be derived it has a secondary dimension
Force is a secondary dimension.
Its dimensions are M L T to the minus 2, consistent with F equals m a. In the British Gravitational system, force is a primary dimension represented by the pound-force; the other basic units are feet, seconds, and Rankine.
This is called the FLT-theta system. In the BG system, mass is a secondary dimension expressed as F T squared L to the minus 1.
okay so you can use either way but in South Korea we use the SI system in then you may wonder which country uses a BG system
of course Australia I guess and then America and India so interestingly England they I think they are using as they converted into a SI unit so they're using the SI system
and why this dimension is important when you are developing the equation governing equation of the fluid mechanics
In a governing equation, terms connected by addition or subtraction must have exactly the same dimensions. This requirement is called the principle of dimensional homogeneity: all equations must be dimensionally homogeneous.
In other words, every additive term in an equation must have the same dimensions.
As an example, consider the Bernoulli equation. Later we will derive it from fundamental physical laws.
Those fundamental laws include conservation of mass, conservation of momentum, and conservation of energy.
With assumptions such as steady and incompressible flow, those governing equations can reduce to a simple form.
That simple relation is called the Bernoulli equation.
The fundamental physical laws governing a fluid system are conservation of mass, momentum, and energy. With simplifying assumptions such as steady, incompressible flow, the momentum or energy equation can be reduced to the Bernoulli equation.
One pressure form is p plus rho V squared over 2 plus rho g z equals a constant. The sum therefore has the same value at two states along the applicable flow.
The p term is static pressure, rho V squared over 2 is dynamic pressure, and rho g z is the elevation contribution. Every term must have the unit of pressure: newtons per square meter.
Using the units of density and velocity squared confirms that rho V squared has units of force per area. Thus every term in this Bernoulli equation has the dimensions of pressure.
Pressure has dimensions M L to the minus 1 T to the minus 2, so the constant must have the same dimensions. Theoretical fluid-mechanics equations are dimensionally consistent when one coherent unit system is used.
This leads to the important distinction between a system and a control volume. In solid mechanics, the material of interest often has a clearly defined boundary.
For fluid flow, the selected region is not always obvious. A system is a fixed quantity of mass, also called a closed system or control mass. Everything external to it is the surroundings, and the interface is its boundary.
The interface between the system and the surroundings is called the boundary.
The piston-cylinder provides an example. The gas inside the cylinder is the system, and the piston can move from x1 to x2.
The gas has pressure, volume, and temperature. Its upper boundary moves with the piston, while the other boundaries are fixed.
volume so control volume sorry for the bad handwriting a control volume is defined as an arbitrary region so in the fluid we can our control volume can be arbitrary
in space through which fluid flows the control volume can be at rest or in motion it doesn't matter for example
so this is a right so this is a moving boundary so this is a moving boundary and this is the fixed boundary right and then second one is the inverse T-shaped pipe and it is the dashed control volume with the dashed interface that is the control volume and then we have one inlet and two outlets and here along the wall
Along the pipe wall, the control surface is a real surface. Across the inlet and outlets, no physical wall exists, so we introduce imaginary surfaces and track the fluid entering and leaving the control volume.
The geometric boundary that separates a control volume from its surroundings is called the control surface.
okay control surface and then the control surface can be real or imaginary okay then for the when we are describing the fluid flow there are two
There are two ways to describe fluid motion. The Lagrangian perspective follows the trajectories of individual particles or bodies.
what we mean by that is if you think about uh air is moving although we consider fluid as a continuum so we often
Although we usually treat a fluid as a continuum, imagine identifying and following a representative fluid particle.
The Lagrangian description follows that particle as it moves.
It describes the motion and changing position of the selected particle.
The Eulerian description instead fixes the reference coordinates at selected locations and describes flow properties as functions of spatial coordinates and time.
For pipe flow, a fixed coordinate r can locate a point in the pipe, and u of r can represent the velocity measured at that location.
at this location r and this r is Eulerian because your r equals zero that is at the center of the pipe is defined as as a reference and that doesn't change right
but on the other hand if you think about this block although this is not really a fluid but you can consider
something like that something like that something like that like the rocket right when the rocket is moving launch it from the ground to shoot into the space but there is a plume if you want to calculate how to calculate the properties of the plume and
and also it is related to the trajectories right then you may consider you as an observer sitting on top of the rocket or you sitting on top of the
If an observer moves with a rocket, aircraft, or block, the observer's reference position changes with time.
That moving reference illustrates the Lagrangian viewpoint, whereas a coordinate fixed at the pipe center does not change with time.
This is the key distinction: a Lagrangian reference follows the moving material, while an Eulerian reference is fixed in space.
When an entire system moves, the Lagrangian perspective may be easier; rotating machinery is one possible example.
or Eulerian meaning you have a control volume that is fixed in space then you want to you are looking into the fluid that is coming in to the control surface volume and that is coming out from the control surface your perspective is fixed inside the properties inside fixed control volume that is the Eulerian then you may wonder what is
more practical so it depends on problem so sometimes Lagrangian framework is more practical or it's easier sometimes Eulerian is easier so there are gonna be a translation from a formula between Lagrangian perspective and Eulerian perspective so at some point I think
Now consider thermodynamic properties. Pressure is a compressive normal stress at a point in a static fluid. A pressure difference or pressure gradient often drives internal flow, such as pipe flow.
If flow moves from state 1 to state 2 in a pipe, the pressure at state 1 is generally higher than the pressure at state 2. The pressure difference drives the motion.
so that's a state one so that's a state one so that's a state one so that's why you know fluid flow from high pressure to the low pressure so pressure difference is the driving force and then temperature is related to the internal energy we will denote that as a small u internal energy level of a fluid and like the pressure difference if the pressure difference is there they're gonna be a force right for the temperature difference there's gonna be a heat
Likewise, a temperature difference causes heat transfer. Fourier's law describes heat flow from higher temperature toward lower temperature. The slide also compares Rankine, Fahrenheit, kelvin, and Celsius.
The four temperature scales shown are Rankine, Fahrenheit, kelvin, and Celsius.
Specific weight, denoted by gamma, is fluid weight per unit volume, so gamma equals rho g. Specific gravity is the ratio of a fluid density to the density of a standard reference fluid.
For gases, the reference is usually air, with density about 1.205 kilograms per cubic meter. For liquids, the reference is usually water at 4 degrees Celsius, with density about 1000 kilograms per cubic meter. Specific gravity is dimensionless.
meter cube okay so here specific weights will be distinctive is a unique to an individual medium like water or air that specific way is a different and then total energy energy is another property the more property the more dynamic property of the fluid when we are saying the energy you have to think about three
types of the energy one is the internal energy energy you and then kinetic energy it is the energy when you are moving at the velocity v and then if you are up in the in the air or low in the low in the ground then because of that difference in altitude you will have the potential energy
That third contribution is potential energy.
Total energy is the sum of internal, kinetic, and potential energy. In fluid mechanics, we commonly express total energy per unit mass.
The specific total energy is e equals u plus one-half V squared plus g z: internal energy per unit mass, kinetic energy per unit mass, and potential energy per unit mass.
So that is the total energy.
Then we also need to have the state relation.
So state meaning state is a very interesting term, right?
So state can define the properties of your fluid at some instance.
So for the gas, the simplest state relation for gases at relative high temperature and low pressure is the ideal gas law.
The ideal-gas law in density form is p equals rho R T.
That is rho, R, T, where, so here, this R is the specific gas constant, right?
This is the specific gas constant per mass, specific gas constant.
The specific gas constant R is related to the specific heats by R equals c-p minus c-v.
What is Cp?
c-p is the specific heat at constant pressure, and c-v is the specific heat at constant volume.
So in a thermodynamics course, so in a thermodynamics course, so in a thermodynamics course, we will derive those kind of relations, so I don't go over.
The specific-heat ratio k is c-p divided by c-v.
So for an ideal gas, so for an ideal gas, we know that k, k is 1.4, and if we use this two relation, R, what's going on?
Using R equals c-p minus c-v and k equals c-p over c-v gives c-v equals R divided by k minus 1, and c-p equals k R divided by k minus 1.
So you can have those specific heat, so you can have those specific heat as a known constant of the specific gas constant and specific heat ratio.
Liquids are treated differently from ideal gases.
A liquid does not use the ideal-gas state law.
Instead, a liquid is often modeled as nearly incompressible.
Because its density changes very little, a liquid is commonly approximated as incompressible.
So here I brought up a very important concept, compressible versus incompressible, compressible versus incompressible.
So at some point, I will go over the mathematical definition, physical and mathematical definition of those two differences.
Compressible, compressible, compressible, compressible, compressible meaning you can compress your liquid, you can compress your air, which is easier.
The gas, right?
So liquid, it's very difficult to compress.
So it is called incompressible, and gas can be compressible, and gas can be compressible.
For a gas flow, compressibility effects are assessed by comparing the flow velocity with the speed of sound.
When the flow speed is much lower than the speed of sound, a gas can often be treated as incompressible. As the speed becomes a significant fraction of the speed of sound, compressibility becomes important.
The velocity does not have to exceed the speed of sound for compressibility effects to matter.
What matters is the flow speed relative to the speed of sound.
At sufficiently low relative speed, the incompressible approximation is appropriate.
Thus even a gas can be treated as incompressible at low speed.
So in chapter 9, I'll talk, I'll briefly talk about compressible flow.
And then some important properties of the fluid flow, a viscosity, we call it as a mu here.
And what is the viscosity?
If we give a shear stress on the fluid, fluid system, then fluid doesn't, fluid will have the strain rate, right?
So that is related to the viscosity.
So how big is the strain rate under a given shear stress?
That is unique to the material to material, like the oil.
What is the viscosity of the air, oil?
What is the viscosity of the water?
What is the viscosity of the air?
So fluid strain rate is different under a given shear stress.
A fluid that follows a linear relation between shear stress and strain rate is called a Newtonian fluid.
So here, tau is the shear stress.
In a simple one-dimensional shear flow, the strain rate is d-u over d-y, and tau equals mu times d-u over d-y.
So if that's our, so this is the strain rate.
So this is the strain rate, and this is the stress for the 1d, the simple case.
If the proportionality coefficient mu is constant at the specified state, the stress-strain-rate relation is linear.
Then it's called a Newtonian fluid.
Mu is a constant.
So this is the stress for the fluid.
If shear stress is not linearly proportional to strain rate, the material is non-Newtonian.
Then there is a called a non-Newtonian fluid.
Like your viscosity changes.
How sticky is your fluid changes depending on the temperature.
So, like your oil.
Your oil is very sticky.
It's very highly viscous at a room temperature.
But if you boil it at a high temperature, your oil becomes very watery, right?
So they have a low viscosity at high temperature for an oil.
Okay.
So viscosity, at some point, I'll talk about that.
And this mu, and this relation is very important.
And so we had this fluid element.
If the top of a small fluid element has a velocity increment delta u relative to the bottom, the element undergoes continuous shear deformation.
Very, very tiny, tiny one.
Let delta theta denote the small angular deformation accumulated during delta t.
The top surface moves a distance delta u times delta t relative to the bottom.
For a small angle, tangent of delta theta is approximately delta theta.
Dividing the relative displacement by the element height delta y gives the deformation angle, and the limit gives d-theta over d-t equals d-u over d-y.
And then you can derive this relation.
We will return to this derivation later.
This mu is a very important concept.
Then probably one of the most important concept for you guys, as a junior student, that is the Reynolds number.
Reynolds number is very unique in fluid mechanics.
So, like solid mechanics or dynamics.
They don't define Reynolds number.
Reynolds number is the ratio of the inertial force over viscous force.
Mathematically, the Reynolds number is written as follows.
The Reynolds number is rho V L divided by mu, or equivalently V L divided by nu.
So, mu is the viscosity.
Here rho is density, V is velocity, L is a reference length, and mu is dynamic viscosity. For flow around a cylinder, the reference length can be its diameter. The ratio mu over rho is the kinematic viscosity nu. With the same fluid and length scale, Reynolds number increases with velocity.
So if your car is moving at lower speed or high speed, then when you are looking into the fluids surrounding the car, while the same viscosity, the velocity is different.
Then in fluid perspective, we say, okay, Reynolds number is much higher for the air that surrounding the moving car at a high speed.
Okay, that's important. So I really want you to spend some time on what is the physical meaning of the Reynolds number and also the what is the mathematical meaning of the Reynolds number.
Some examples of how the viscosity works. This is not quite an important example, but I want to go over.
Consider a block of weight W sliding down an inclined plane while lubricated by a thin film of oil.
a block of weight W. So, we have to have the oil, but we have the force diagram in x-direction, right?
So sigma of f x is we have the w here and this is the theta. So w sine theta of this one, right?
Along the incline, the downslope component of weight is W sine theta, while viscous resistance is tau A in the opposite direction.
At terminal velocity there is no acceleration, so the force balance is W sine theta minus tau A equals zero.
Assuming a linear velocity distribution across the oil film, tau equals mu times V over h.
The velocity gradient in the oil film is V divided by h.
Substitution into the force balance gives the terminal velocity. We next consider how viscosity varies with temperature.
changes with the temperature so this is quite um high level situation probably as a junior student like you you
don't consider viscosity changing uh with respect to temperature but uh let's think about i briefly introduce
the situation so for the gas and liquid temperature behaves differently for the viscosity
For a gas, viscosity increases when temperature increases. For a liquid, viscosity decreases when temperature increases.
viscosity decreases right so uh that's why for a re-entry vehicle like rockets right so at the because it's such uh it's a moving such a high velocity
viscosity increases a lot so you have to have more fuel but for the liquid um if the temperature is higher viscosity decreases
Gas viscosity is often estimated with a power law or Sutherland's law.
For liquids, viscosity can be estimated with an empirical temperature correlation.
The constants in that correlation are determined experimentally, using a reference temperature T-naught and reference viscosity mu-naught.
room temperature, room temperature and viscosity at that room temperature. So for the water, we can define t-naught, mu-naught, and adjusted values of the constants are fitted into those values.
And then surface tension, you know the surface tension very well. It is a liquid, so let's say that you have a water droplet, liquid, and outside is the gas. This is a water drop, right?
So a liquid being unable to expand freely will form an interface with a second liquid or a gas. So they form an interface with a gas, right?
And then we define hydrophilic, meaning wet the solid quite well, or hydrophobic, meaning the liquid is not wetting the surface, right?
So you may have heard of hydrophilic surface or hydrophobic surface. During the rainy days, you want to have the clothes with the hydrophobic surface so that it doesn't wet very well, right?
So how can you define hydrophilic surface? So how can you define hydrophilic or hydrophobic?
The contact angle theta is measured where the liquid-gas interface meets the solid. If theta is less than 90 degrees, the liquid wets the solid and the surface is hydrophilic.
So if this is not wetting, it's not wetting, it's not wetting, it is hydrophobic, okay? So this is theta, theta here and theta here is smaller than 90 for the hydrophilic, greater than 90 for the hydrophobic.
If theta is greater than 90 degrees, the surface is hydrophobic. Surface tension is denoted by an uppercase gamma in this slide.
And I didn't go over, I don't want to go over the details of surface tension. Most of the details are in your textbook.
shown in this one.
shown in this one, equal and opposite force,
equal and opposite force,
The equal and opposite surface-tension forces are exposed normal to the cut.
Okay?
Here, so this is a cut. So your surface tension is acting this way, this direction. If this is a cut, it's acting that direction.
And then vapor pressure. What is a vapor pressure? So that is related to the liquid.
So when does liquid boils? So when does liquid boils at certain pressure? That is the vapor pressure. So pressure at which a liquid boils and is in equilibrium with its own vapor.
Boiling begins when the liquid pressure reaches the vapor pressure at the specified temperature.
The vapor pressure of the water is about 2.34 kPa. Okay? So at this point, we don't consider temperature. Temperature is constant. You have water. And then you can change the pressure.
At 20 degrees Celsius, the vapor pressure of water is about 2.34 kilopascals. If local absolute pressure is reduced to this value, water can boil. This can occur near a rapidly rotating underwater propeller and lead to cavitation.
The Bernoulli relation helps explain why high local velocity can be accompanied by low local pressure.
When the local liquid pressure drops below the vapor pressure, vapor bubbles can form.
When those vapor bubbles move into a higher-pressure region, they collapse violently. Repeated collapse can damage and erode a propeller surface.
For example, if water accelerates in a pump from rest to about 50 feet per second, its pressure can drop by about 15 pound-force per square inch.
That is about 1 atm or 103 kilopascal. So this can cause the cavitation, which means that we will have the gas bubble.
Okay, so this vapor pressure is very important in cavitation and in ocean engineering, folks, cavitation is a very important topic that many people are studying still over by experiment or by numerical method.
Now I'll talk about the stream flow patterns. So there are streamlines, pathlines, and streaklines.
These have different definitions. A streamline is a line everywhere tangent to the velocity vector at a given instant.
So let's assume that inner figure 1a, so these are the streamlines, and then at any, these are the streamlines, and any location, if you put a tangent line, there is the velocity of the local velocity vector.
Because the differential displacement d-r along a streamline is parallel to the velocity vector V, we can write the streamline equation.
The streamline equation relates the coordinate differentials to the corresponding velocity components.
In Cartesian coordinates, d-x over u equals d-y over v equals d-z over w.
Okay, pathline is a actual path traversed by a given fluid particle.
A streakline is the locus of particles that have passed through a prescribed point.
In other words, a streakline collects the trajectories of all particles that previously passed through one fixed point.
Streamlines, pathlines, and streaklines are identical in steady flow, but they can differ in unsteady flow.
So that's left for your take-home homework. But you know I don't give you a homework so far. So there will be a homework at the end of the chapter, chapter 2, chapter 3. But for chapter 1 I may give you a very simple concept questions but not any mathematically solving questions.
Now consider basic flow-analysis techniques. In solid mechanics, a free-body diagram is a central tool for analysis.
fluid mechanics. But for the fluid mechanics, you will have the system, well-defined system and a control volume. Then you will, in all cases, whether you are using a system or a control volume, flow must satisfy the three basic laws of the mechanics.
What are those? What are those? What are those? What are those? Those are the conservation of mass,
conservation of the momentum, whether they are linear or angular momentum, and then conservation of energy. Okay. So those are, we will derive the governing equation of the fluid flow based on the three physical laws.
The three basic laws are conservation of mass, conservation of linear or angular momentum, and conservation of energy.
We also need an equation of state and the associated boundary conditions.
And we need the equation of state, state relations, and then associated boundary condition. So as long as we have a governing physics, and one additional state relations, and then boundary condition, there is a difference from problem to problem to problem, then we can solve the pressure at any location in your problem.
The first flow-analysis technique is the integral approach, introduced in Chapter 3. It applies the conservation laws to a finite control volume and balances what enters, leaves, and accumulates.
The differential approach instead considers an infinitesimally small control volume and derives equations that describe the detailed flow field point by point.
The differential approach produces differential governing equations, whereas the integral approach produces integral balance equations.
For experimental analysis, we use dimensional analysis and the Pi theorem. Consider testing a large aircraft such as the KF-21.
Full-scale flight tests and detailed pressure or temperature measurements can be difficult, so engineers often use a smaller model in a wind tunnel.
For a scaled wind-tunnel model, we must determine the velocity and pressure conditions that reproduce the relevant behavior of the full-size aircraft.
Dimensional analysis identifies the nondimensional parameters that must match between the model and the full-scale condition.
The Pi theorem supports that matching. Computational fluid dynamics, or CFD, is another common engineering tool. Integral, differential, and dimensional approaches can be sufficient for simple problems, but many modern flows are much more complicated.
complicated like what if you have a chemical reaction for the combustion how can you integrate right so for the combustion you also have to think about the fuel fuel particle as well so in that case you have to have combination of the continuum of a background air and also the particle of the fuel
so in that case it's very difficult to directly apply a dimensional analysis. In that case you will have the computational fluid dynamic CFD technique with multiple CPUs and GPUs to calculate many millions over tens of millions of state variables.
Before we have computers, then how can people calculate the pressure of any certain location or temperature? How can you do that?
Many fundamental discoveries in fluid mechanics occurred during the eighteenth and nineteenth centuries.
Archimedes established the laws of buoyancy and floating bodies. Leonardo da Vinci formulated an early continuity equation, and Isaac Newton proposed the law of linear viscous stress.
Leonhard Euler developed Bernoulli's equation by solving the basic equations.
The Navier-Stokes existence and smoothness problem is one of the seven Millennium Prize Problems.
The Navier-Stokes equations are fundamental governing equations for fluid flow.
Navier formulated basic differential equations for viscous flow.
Jean Louis Poiseuille performed early experiments on laminar flow in tubes.
what is the physical meaning of what is the physical meaning of what is the physical meaning of the laminar flow.
And then Reynolds. Early on, I asked you to think quite deep about Reynolds numbers, right?
So explain the phenomenon of the transition to the turbulence. So laminar, turbulence, transition.
Ludwig Prandtl developed boundary-layer theory and explained flow separation.
Theodore von Karman made major advances in aerodynamics and turbulence theory.
So at some point in our course, you will run into those names in some equation form. Okay. So those are the summary.
So chapter one is all about introductory of the fluid mechanics. And in chapter two, I will move on to a more practical and theoretical aspects of the fluid mechanics. Thank you.